[Music]
okay
oh hi we are the we are here with
BuzzFeed to play with puppies and answer
your
[Music]
[Applause]
questions
[Music]
we like to get hot pot once we get back
to Korea and we have a day off we
actually talked about this yesterday we
were like we need to get hot pot again
and we like to ride bikes and go
shopping I know the two of us went to um
get
Mar are you okay s so cute oh and like
to play OverWatch OverWatch
OverWatch play the
[Music]
[Laughter]
game
[Music]
life is content just always have
fun
oh my God a freestyle WAP oh my
God I like my
puppy so sweet puppy
puppies of Sur this is
s having a
fun are T
tless the intro he's tired out that
one's tired out
[Music]
panting
wow
definitely
[Music]
God she's she training them right now in
real
[Music]
time ah okay do it right now we do this
all the time set
let's
little handshake we do every time we go
up on
[Music]
stage okay
acts of service words of affirmation
words of affirmation and touch and
present
yeah
oh so cute I really am a big fan of BBA
doobie so one day I would
hope and also I spoke I had an
interaction with ly on Twitter once and
I would really like to work on that like
develop that idea so yeah
rodo
I would love to sing with her one
[Music]
day classic
classic
[Music]
sending it girl
energy girl energy the good place you
don't
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I don't
know keep doing what you like even if
people tell you you're weird weird being
weird will make you
cool you guys want love it's okay
everybody's got love for
[Laughter]
you this one's very calm I feel
[Music]
like
spee
[Music]
doctor she was to become a doctor in the
Netherlands we went to Soho yesterday
and we were talking about how like maybe
like what if like in another lifetime
she continued doing ballet and I
continued doing musicals and then we met
in New York yeah that would have been so
cool
[Music]
she she looks very cold but she also
very
smart
cute I would like to be kaha oh
wa oh also just like P
how I would like touch my abs and like
feel
[Music]
satisfied a little burn out oh this is
this one's so quiet name isak because
because you're calm you're
quiet
hey do
is this do is do is
[Music]
the
seraphim oh yeah she has a puppy maybe
she could bring her puppy
bring bring to New York and I'll bring
my dog I have a dog named he's
a
[Music]
we have a lot of things in store a lot
of new music and a lot of new fun
difficult
choreography yes yes World Tour and the
world tour
hopefully hi
taka burn thank you boss these puppies
are all adoptable from Rescue city thank
you so much for helping us thank you by
[Applause]
by
[Music]
n